[Applaudissements]
si vous avez au cinéma voir un film
d'action vous verrez certainement des
scènes extraordinaires et pourtant qui
vous paraîtront complètement crédible
[Musique]
c'est pas toujours bien fait mais
regardez plutôt attentivement cet
extrait où le visage de la princesse
leia et entièrement créés en images de
synthèse
aujourd'hui les effets spéciaux sont si
bien fait que vous ne faites plus la
distinction entre la partie origines
originale de l'image et la partie
truqués vous fait bluffer bien sûr vous
savez que tout ceci n'est pas réel
puisque vous êtes au cinéma si
maintenant je vous disais que ce type de
trucage est en train de devenir si
facile à réaliser qui va envahir notre
quotidien et altérer notre perception de
la réalité est ce que vous êtes prêt à
me croire alors je suis un créatif et un
technophile depuis plus de 15 ans je
travaille dans le domaine de la 3d et
j'adore explorer en fait les nouvelles
technologies pour comprendre leur
potentiel leur impact et pour les
utiliser à mon tour est justement une
des choses les plus compliqués à faire
en images de synthèse c'est à dire à
rendre crédible
ce sont les personnages humains donc
quand le cinéma d'hollywood nous en
montre vous devez bien prendre
conscience des moyens qui sont déployés
des rites derrière pour générer ces
images il faut du temps et il faut de
l'argent
beaucoup de préparation en amont des
moyens techniques comme des combinaisons
de capture de mouvements bien des
studios font vert et aussi surtout
beaucoup beaucoup de personnes
talentueuses mais une nouvelle manière
de créer des images réalistes est en
train d'émerger
grâce à une branche de l'intelligence
artificielle et je pense que ça va
radicalement changer la façon de
manipuler la réalité alors cette branche
de l'intelligence artificielle s'appelle
le dip learning ou apprentissage profond
en français donc ça s'applique à
l'informatique est en gros c'est un
ensemble de deux méthodes qui permettent
un apprentissage automatique
ces méthodes sont extrêmement
performante pour analyser pour
reconnaître pour synthétiser des données
et c'est ça que je trouve génial en fait
c'est que la machine puisse apprendre
par elle même et être créatrice à son
tour alors lenval a débuté aux environs
en 2010 et ce sont maintenant des
milliards qui sont investis dans le
domaine le domaine progresse très vite
et aujourd'hui on arrive à modifier
voire à synthétiser
des personnes en vidéo voici quelques
exemples ici le visage de nicholas cage
a été inséré
à la place de l'actrice principale
est ce c'est automatiquement grâce à une
intelligence artificielle la des
chercheurs nous montrent comment il est
possible de transférer nos mouvements de
tête et nos expressions sur une autre
personne donc on devient finalement
marionnettiste et ce type de technique
permet aussi d'éditer finalement l'image
de quelqu'un de manière très intuitive
donc si on pouvait aller est ce qu'on
peut aller au delà du visage est-ce
qu'on peut aller jusqu'aux corps et
biens allons-y
on prend une danseuse professionnelle en
vidéo on demande à des gens de bouger
n'importe comment devant la caméra
[Musique]
et l'intelligence artificielle leur
applique les mouvements donc aujourd'hui
tout le monde peut danser comme des pros
les justes en vidéo alors c'est ces
vidéos on voit des personnes qui sont
modifiés par l'intelligence artificielle
s'appelle ddip fake c'est la contraction
du mot diplôme ning donc la méthode
l'apprentissage profonde et de fake
le mot anglais qui veut dire faut donc
des dix fake alors qu'est ce que
l'intelligence artificielle bien changé
bah ce qui est révolutionnaire
finalement c'est que bientôt vous allez
tous pouvoir faire ce type de trucage là
chez vous contrairement à ce que je
mentionnais pour l'industrie du cinéma
avec ces outils vous n'avez plus besoin
de talents vous n'avez pas besoin de
connaissances techniques en vidéo vous
avez plus besoin d'autant de temps et
certaines de ses technologies comme
celle qui permet de permuter les visages
sont déjà disponibles elles sont
gratuites elles sont en open source
vous devez juste avoir finalement un
ordinateur chez vous et voici la preuve
donc ça c'est moi voici un exemple d'une
réalité altérer de manière automatique
grâce à une intelligence artificielle
pour l'instant ni rien mais ça c'est mon
ami franck dont le visage vient
remplacer le mien dans la vidéo voici un
exemple d'une réalité altérer de manière
automatique grâce à une intelligence
artificielle
alors comment est ce que j'ai fait pour
faire cette vidéo
c'était assez facile en fait j'ai
téléchargé le logiciel puis j'ai demandé
à franck de se filmer des petites vidéos
cinq minutes en tout les a envoyés j'ai
fait la même chose je me suis filmé et
ça dans un premier temps ça m'a permis
de collecter un grand nombre de photos
qui nous représente et qui a présenté
nos visages et dans un deuxième temps
j'ai donné tout ça au programme qui a
regardé chaque photo et qui a appris à
reconnaître nos visages et à synthétiser
synthétiser aussi nos visages donc cette
phase là après environ
deux jour s'appelle la phase
d'apprentissage et enfin j'ai donné en
fait une vidéo
en entrée dans le programme avec moi
dessus et le programme a automatiquement
généré la vidéo truquée avec franck en
moins de deux minutes
j'aurais pu donner n'importe quelle
vidéo de moi en entrée vous voyez c'est
facile ça accessible c'est pas cher
alors bien sûr il ya quelques défauts
toujours qu'on peut voir dans ces vidéos
des problèmes de flou de résolution de
scintillement mais le domaine évolue
tellement vite que bientôt nous n'y
verront que du feu
donc ça c'est pour la vidéo et pour le
son est bien les avancées sont majeurs
également on arrive aujourd'hui à créer
des voix de synthèse qui paraît si
naturel qu'on peut quasiment plus les
distinguer de celles des hommes et
plusieurs sociétés travaillent sur des
technologies donc toujours basé sur cet
apprentissage profond qui permettent
d'imiter de reproduire la voix de
n'importe qui juste à partir d'un
enregistrement de la voix
donc là on peut se dire mais en
combinant ces deux techniques
je peux faire faire et faire dire
n'importe quoi à presque n'importe qui
alors pourquoi presque c'est parce qu'il
faut des données en amont sur la
personne pour la phase d'apprentissage
l'ordre de grandeur c'est des milliers
d' images et quelques minutes
d'enregistrement de l'avant alors des
milliers de l'image alors faites vous
vous dites c'est bon il est loin
d'exister
millimages le représentant a peut-être
détrompez-vous parce que 1000 images
c'est uniquement 40 secondes de vidéo
autrement dit c'est assez facile à
obtenir
on va reprendre dans le détail ce qu'on
peut faire avec ces techniques donc
acquis une cette technique là je peux
mettre le visage de quelqu'un sur le
corps de quelqu'un d'autre je peux
comment dire je peux éviter les
mouvements je peux faire faire des
mouvements à quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
fait je peux placer une personne dans un
contexte n'a jamais été et on peut même
en fait inventé ce qu'elle va dire alors
c'est je trouve ça c'est très
impressionnant
ça peut paraître aussi un petit peu
effrayant il ya de vrai potentiel
créatif pour cette technologie c'est sûr
pour tous ceux qui veulent s'en emparer
et on peut penser justement à
l'industrie du cinéma qui pourrait
produire plus facilement et à moindre
coût
et d'ailleurs ça pourrait ouvrir de
nouvelles perspectives
imaginez-vous par exemple avec vos amis
dans un film personnalisés mais ce qui
est beaucoup plus questionnant
finalement c'est la puissance des
dérives possibles
certains voient les deep fake comme
étant la première véritable menace de
l'intelligence artificielle
les personnalités sont les principales
cibles pour l'instant parce que il est
très facile de collecter des médias des
données sur elle et donc les premières
personnes vraiment touchés ont été des
actrices et des chanteuses dont le
visage a été inséré dans des films
pornographiques
et puis il ya eu aussi des parodies
mettant en scène des acteurs mais aussi
des hommes politiques comme vladimir
poutine angela merkel ou donald trump
mais en politique est ce que ça va
s'arrêter à l'humour probablement que
non vous savez l'information est une
arme et donc l'utilisation des dites
fait comme outil de propagande peut
faire des ravages
voici une vidéo faite par le réalisateur
john jordan pile pour justement éveiller
les consciences sont moins
impressionnants alors
imaginez comment nous pouvons tous être
manipulés si le discours d'un homme
politique peut être créée de toutes
pièces
on peut penser aussi que si ce type de
vidéos se répand dans les médias mais
finalement un homme politique puisse
nier ses propos en disant attendait ça
c'était une vidéo truquée donc en gros
un scandale qui aurait réellement eu
lieu pourrait être déclaré comme ne
s'étant jamais produit et au delà de
l'individu il peut y avoir aussi des
états qui peuvent être pris pour cible
par d'autres états ou par des
groupuscules qui voudraient semer la
confusion
un dernier exemple prenez le pdg d'une
société connue fait lui faire n'importe
quoi vous diffuser la vidéo vous pouvez
discréditer son entreprise ou manipuler
le cours de l'action alors aujourd'hui
tous ces scénarios là sont possibles
sont plausibles
car l'information qu'elle soit vraie ou
fausse se propage de manière massive
quasiment instantanée sur les réseaux
sociaux
dès lors qu'elle est sensationnel et
puis avoue qu'en est il de vous est ce
que vous partager des photos ou des
vidéos personnelles sur les réseaux
sociaux
si oui cela pourrait être en fait de la
matière première qui pourrait utiliser à
des fins mal intentionné comme du
chantage de l'usurpation d'identité la
taille de votre réputation
d'ailleurs sur le point sur le point
légal ou est-ce qu'on en ait ben on est
en plein flottement est ce que faire des
dips chèque est illégal est ce que c'est
moral puisqu'on utilise des outils
finalement tout dépend de ce qu'on en
fait avec un marteau vous pouvez
bricoler vous pouvez vous en servir
comme une arme et si vous en êtes
victime que dit la loi mais pas de
réponse claire à ce jour un point
vraiment crucial juridique lui aussi
c'est la notion de preuves
aujourd'hui les fichiers audio et vidéo
peuvent être reçus comme des pièces à
conviction mais vous avez vu ça peut
être falsifiée voire complètement créé
toutes pièces donc comment est-ce qu'on
peut encore les recevoir si finalement
on n'a aucune garantie sur leur
fiabilité
alors comment
comment savoir si une vidéo est
authentique
comment éviter de se faire duper
comment éviter que ces vidéos là se
répandent il n'y a pas une seule réponse
mais plutôt un panel d'actions qui
finalement engage tout le monde
et voici quelques axes la première
question qu'on pourrait se poser c'est
est ce qu'on peut stopper la technologie
est ce qu'on peut interdire son
utilisation bien empêcher sa diffusion
bon c'est difficile parce que certains
logiciels sont déjà là déjà disponibles
et puis la recherche avance les
chercheurs nous montrent de nouveaux
résultats bluffants qu'il publie
certains s'en emparent pour de bonnes ou
mauvaises intentions
dans ce cas ce qu'on peut pas utiliser
la technologie pour nous aider à
enquêter finalement à détecter ces types
fake
alors le sujet est pris très au sérieux
surtout lorsque le trucage en fait est
parfait pour l'oeil humain
les chercheurs qui travaillent sur les
outils qui permettent de faire ces dites
fake sont aussi ceux qui travaillent sur
les moyens et détecter parce qu'ils sont
conscients des dérives potentielles
développe des algorithmes et parmi ces
algorithmes on a des plutôt intéressant
certains algorithmes regarde si la
personne dans la vidéo cligne des yeux
de manière naturelle
d'autres algorithmes vérifie qui a une
cohérence du flux sanguin entre la
partie du coût et la partie du visage
d'autres algorithmes encore recherche il
existe une vidéo antérieure mais qui
serait très similaire à celle qu'on
étudie et enfin une espèce de méthode
générale c'est finalement d'entraîner
tout simplement une intelligence
artificielle à détecter ces dix fake
alors où est ce qu'on peut déployer ces
technologies de détection
tout d'abord chez vous lorsque vous êtes
sur internet un petit peu à l'image des
antivirus
on voit apparaître des extensions qui
font des vérifications sur tous les
médias qui sont présents dans votre page
et qui peuvent vous alerter sur des
potentiels falsification mais le
l'endroit il me semble plus pertinent
pour déployer ses techniques là c'est
l'endroit où l'information se diffuse de
manière massive c'est à dire les
plateformes médiatiques youtube ou les
réseaux sociaux
donc si détecter ces dites fait que
devrait-il faire ce qui devrait les
supprimer priori non parce que tout dit
fais ce n'est pas dangereux
mais est ce qu'il ne serait pas de leurs
responsabilités finalement de détecter
de les détecter
dès qu'une vidéo est ajoutée sur leurs
serveurs et tout simplement de nous
alerter en nous disant attention cette
vidéo est falsifié ou potentiellement
falsifiés les états aussi ont un rôle
important à jouer parce que globalement
l'intelligence artificielle va
transformer notre société un peu dans la
mesure où internet déjà transformé
auparavant et les grandes entreprises le
savez c'est pour ça qu'elle investisse
massivement et donc en conséquence les
états doivent aussi s'intéresser
investir anticipé cette technologie les
comprendre pour nous protéger parce
qu'il n'ya pas que des enjeux
économiques à l'intelligence
artificielle est spécifiquement les
agences de sécurité nationale doivent
s'approprier ce sujet là ce sujet des
deep tech
mais le point central finalement c'est
nous c'est notre sens critique
il est important de savoir que ces
technologies là existent on peut
facilement se faire tromper et
aujourd'hui faire ce tedx me permets de
vous en parler
donc face à de l'information
sensationnel il faut faire preuve de
discernement
il faut pas hésiter à douter parfois
enquêter a essayé de retrouver la source
de l'information
bon ce genre de d'investigation prend du
temps demande parfois des compétences
alors il serait bon que nous allions sur
des sites où l'information est fiable
fiable ça veut dire où les faits ont été
vérifiés et où les sources sont tracées
wikipédia est un bon exemple
parce que l'encyclopédie cette
encyclopédie la recense toutes les
sources et nous alerte sur une page
lorsque à lire et manquant aucune
information et peu fiables et tout cela
grâce à des centaines de milliers de
contributeurs et en 2017 son fondateur a
annoncé la création de wiki tribune qui
est censé transposer ce modèle là vers
de la news vérifier vérifier cette
fois-ci par des gens plus
professionnelle cip rédacteur ou
journalistes
nous courons nous considérons tous
instinctivement une vidéo comme étant
une capture de ce qui s'est réellement
passé
et pourtant on a vu que la vidéo est pas
forcément un témoin fiable alors
projetons nous juste un instant dans une
époque où il y aura une très très grande
proportion de ces vidéos truquées de ses
10 sec
eh bien nous ne saurions plus ce qui est
faux et donc nous ne serions plus non
plus ce qui est vrai alors va-t-on en
arriver là
dans l'histoire des technologies on voit
que toutes ces nouvelles technologies
qui nous paraissent si menaçante quand
elle nous dépasse sont finalement bien
moins alarmantes camp nou les apprivoise
ont plus la technologie avance plus les
tic plus sens moral plus la vigilance
doivent s'imposer
n'oublions pas c'est nous c'est nous qui
décidons de croire ce que ce que l'on
nous donne à voir
nous allons entrer dans une ère où
assisté par de l'intelligence
artificielle nous pourrions tous être de
véritables faussaires de la réalité
alors pour demain quelle réalité
souhaitons-nous fabriquer
[Applaudissements]